Guten Abend, mein Name ist Lari, ich bin Nasten und für sie ist es so ständig. Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Frank Haus.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Haus?
44 Jahre alt.
Wie bittet ihr, habe sie nicht verstanden?
1982.
1988.
1978.
Erster Mai 1978, Entschuldigung.
Okay.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 groß
und 78 Kilo schwer.
78 Kilo.
Okay.
Wie kann ich Ihnen halten?
Also, es ist so,
dass ich gestern
in der Zeit
den Rasen gemäht habe.
Und dann habe ich
plötzlich einen Schmerz gehabt
in meinem linken Bein.
Das tut sehr weh.
Mein linkes Bein tut sehr weh.
Seit gestern?
Ja, plötzlich aufgetreten.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch Schmerzen jetzt?
Ja.
Sehr starke Schmerzen.
Ja, sehr starke Schmerzen.
Okay.
Wenn diese Schmerzen aufgetreten sind,
haben Sie in der
im Garten gearbeitet.
Noch mal.
Sagen Sie den Satz bitte noch mal.
Wenn diese Schmerzen aufgetreten sind.
Als diese Schmerzen,
als diese Schmerzen aufgetreten, ja wohl.
Ja, als diese Schmerzen, ja wohl.
Haben Sie im Garten gearbeitet.
Richtig.
Ich habe im Garten gearbeitet.
Und dann sind die Schmerzen aufgetreten.
Okay.
Und dieses starke Schmerzen.
Wo genau die Schmerzen sind?
Wo sind die genau?
Das ganze Bein tut mir weh.
Das ganze Bein.
Und der Schenker, oder?
Auch Oberchan.
Das ganze Bein.
Alles das ganze Bein.
Okay.
Außer Schmerzen, haben Sie noch etwas,
in diesem Bein?
Was meinen Sie?
Vielleicht Hautfallbeferendierung,
oder Schwedung.
Es ist heller als das andere Bein.
Heller.
Okay.
Ist dieser Bein geschworen?
Nein, ist es nicht geschworen?
Ist dieser Bein
wärme geworden?
Fühlen Sie das wärme oder?
Das Bein, ist dieses Bein.
Dieses Bein.
Ist Kälte geworden oder?
Ja, es fühlt sich kälter an.
Können Sie dieses Bein bewegen?
Bitte?
Ich kann es bewegen, ja.
Mhm.
Das ganze Bein.
Aber wahrscheinlich tut das mehr weh, oder?
Das kann ich gar nicht sagen.
Wenn ich es bewege, tut es nicht mehr weh.
Also wenn ich jetzt im Sitzen mein Bein bewege,
tut es nicht mehr weh, als das andere.
Es tut immer weh.
Es wird besser, wenn ich sitze.
Wenn ich sitze, ist es besser.
Das meinen Sie das?
Dass es im Sitzen besser wird.
Ja, es wird im Sitzen besser.
Okay.
Wenn ich laufe, gehen, laufen.
Im Deutschen, ich will nur mal kurz sagen,
im Deutschen tut es manchmal meinem laufen weh,
damit meint man aber eigentlich nur gehen.
Also nicht dieses laufen,
sondern das tut es im Gehen, meinen Sie,
wenn ich gehe, ob das weh tut mit bewegen.
Ja, dann tut es mehr weh.
Ist Ihnen ein Auslöser für die sich mit dem Metzen aufgefallen?
Nach der Gardenerarbeit hat es angefangen.
Ich hatte vorher nie beschwerben mit meinem Bein.
Ich mache viel Sport.
Ich bin sehr beweglich.
Ich mache immer nach meinem Garten selber.
Vorher ist so etwas nie aufgetreten gestern das erste Mal.
Okay.
Darf ich dich messen, irgendwo hin aus?
Nur meinen Bein.
Okay.
Haben Sie etwas eingenommen?
Für die Schmerzen?
Für die sich messen, ja.
Ich habe so viele Sachen eingenommen.
Es hilft nichts.
Es tut richtig weh.
Was haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich habe ein Profil eingenommen, Parazita,
nur Valginen eingenommen.
Es wirkt alles nicht. Es hilft nicht.
Okay.
Leiten Sie an irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Nein. Ich habe sonst keine Erkrankungen.
Sie nehmen auch nicht regelmäßige Medikamente ein, oder?
Nein. Ich nehme keine regelmäßigen Medikamente ein.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Ich habe keinen Fieber.
Okay.
Bekommen Sie gut Luft?
Ja.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Nein.
Hab ich nicht.
Ich bin ein Prodoktor. Darf ich Sie etwas fragen?
Ja.
Und gucken Sie so ernst?
Okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Entschuldigung.
Sie haben nie geraucht, oder?
Nein. Nein. Ich bin nicht traurig.
Ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein.
Bei Feierlichkeiten?
Okay.
Also nur bei Gelegenheit?
Haben Sie, oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit dem Druck?
Mit den Drogen, kann man nicht sagen.
Drogen ist ein Wort, da gibt es kein Artikel.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen gehabt?
Also nicht davor ein Artikel setzen?
Nein.
Sie haben keine Krankungen, keine Medikamente.
Nein, ich verstehe das nicht.
Ich bin eigentlich ganz gesund.
Warum tut jetzt auch einmal mein Bein weh?
Das ist unerträglich der Schmerz.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Wo operiert?
Meine Mandeln sind als Kind rausgenommen worden.
Mandel, okay.
Und mein Blinddamm ist entfernt worden.
Als Jugendlicher.
Okay.
Sonst?
Sonst nichts.
Ich denke nach.
Warum denken Sie nach?
Ist es etwas Schlimmes?
Denken Sie nach, wer die sterben jetzt?
Warum denken Sie nach?
Ist es so ernst mit mir?
Ist es so schlimm?
Ich bin jetzt ganz gesund.
Einmal gut.
Weil ja, diese plöstliche Beinschmerzen.
Ist das auch Schlimmes?
Werde ich jetzt sterben?
Ich kann das nicht genau sagen.
Okay.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch noch?
Noch mal bitte den Satz.
Sind Ihre Eltern am Leben oder leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja.
Meine Eltern sind noch am Leben.
Sie leben noch, ja.
Sind Sie gesund?
Meine Eltern, nein.
Bis auf Kleinigkeiten.
Meine Mutter hat Bluthochdruck und Diabetes.
Und mein Vater hat COPD.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ich habe eine Schwester, ja.
Meine Schwester hat auch Diabetes und Bluthochdruck.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Bin ich.
Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe eine Tochter, ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Meine Tochter ist gesund.
Ja gut.
Entschuldigung.
Haben Sie im Ausland in der letzten Zeit?
Nein.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Dachdecker.
Dachdecker.
Wie würden Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Drückend, stichend, dumpf.
Stichend? Das sind stichende Schmerzen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Weder beim Wasserlassen noch beim Stuhlgang?
Das war meine Frage.
Bitte?
Wir haben gesagt, dieses Wein ist nicht geschworen, oder?
Nein.
Ja, es ist nicht geschworen.
Frau Doktor, Sie machen mir Angst.
Das waren meine Fragen.
Ich möchte Sie erst körperlich untersuchen.
Was mache ich jetzt?
Was machen Sie jetzt mit mir?
Das tut so weh.
Ich lege auch einen Zugang.
Können wir ein Arzt Schmerzmittel geben?
Bitte tun Sie das.
Das tut so weh.
Was machen Sie dann?
Muss ich hier bleiben oder kann ich nach Hause gehen?
Wir müssen einmal untersuchen und durchschwören.
Danach sprechen wir noch mal.
Ich kann das jetzt nicht sagen.
Okay.
Bitte beeilen Sie sich, weil ich habe so stark Schmerzen.
Danke schön.
Ich habe noch eine andere Frage.
Schmerzintensität.
Bitte?
Die Schmerzintensität, also auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10,
auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10,
sind meine Schmerzen fast 10.
Ja.
CAPout.
I am data.
I am edit.
Ich kann auftreten, ja. Aber so wie ich es dir schon gesagt habe, den ich ein paar Schritte laufe, tut es sehr, sehr weh.
Secken bis, gefragt oder?
Um Gartenarbeit und...
Was ich war dort um Gartenarbeit, aber ich habe einen Zecken bis habe, ich bin geimpft gegen Zecken.
Und ich habe auch bin auch nicht gebissen worden.
Ich denke alle Fragen gestellt, Herr Kollege. Erst mal.
Ich denke alle Fragen sind gestellt.
Ich denke alle Fragen sind gestellt, Herr Kollege.
Alles klar.
Kann ich jetzt die Erste schäfen?
Gerne.
Ja, ich habe heute etwas anderes gemacht als sonst. Ich wollte es nur sagen.
Ja.
Okay, ja, ich bin bereit.
Guten Tag Frau Oberreisding. Ich würde Ihnen gerne einen Patient vorstellen, den ich gerade gesehen habe.
Haben Sie das?
Jawohl.
Herr Frank, ja, es ist 44 Jahre alt.
Ben ist gerade oder der ist gerade?
Wen oder was? Akkusativ, Wen?
Wen.
Wen ich, genau.
Und bei einer Frau müsste sie sagen, die ich gerade. Akkusativ, Frau ist die.
Okay.
Ja, die ich gerade aufgenommen habe oder gesehen habe. Okay. Ja, bitte.
Ja, Herr Frank.
Ich bin ganz ober.
Okay.
Herr Frank, haus 44 Jahre alt.
Ich stelle sich mit seit gestern bestehenden, plötzlichen,
sehr starke Beinschmerzen in der linke Seite.
Auf der linken Seite.
Die Schmerzen sind stechig.
Ich muss unterbrechen.
Ja.
Das ist alles super. Sie können auch sehr gut Deutsch sprechen, aber da ist ein Fehler.
Und zwar stelle es geht um den Herrn Haust, der sich, er stellt sich.
Vor.
Vor, die Dinge mehr. Habt ihr das gesagt schon?
Nein, ich habe nicht gesagt.
Ich wollte das am Ende sagen und dann habe ich das vergessen.
Und vergessen, genau. Das meinte ich. Alles gut.
Und das ich wollte nur sagen, je länger der Satz, desto mehr Fehler kann man machen.
Man kann auch kurze, kurze Satz machen.
Okay.
Okay, alles gut.
Sonst war alles super.
Ja.
Okay, hat seit gestern hatte er starke Schmerzen auf der linken Seite.
Wo auf der linken Seite?
Ja, die Schmerzen sind stechend.
Und sehr stark.
Und das sind nach der Gartenarbeit aufgetreten.
Die sind nach der, nach der Gartenarbeit aufgetreten.
Ja.
Okay.
Er sagte auch, dieses Bein sind heller geworden.
Aber wie sagt man das?
Nicht moment. Stop.
Kann man sagen. Alles gut.
Nicht dieses Bein ist dieses Bein sind, sondern dieses Bein ist.
Ist nicht sind.
Dieses Bein ist.
Ja, es ist ein.
Alles gut.
Dieses Bein ist.
Ja.
Von der Hauptfarbe er heller.
Hauptfarbe er heller.
Okay.
Er hat über Profanpräsentum und Navagier eingegenommen.
Aber diese Medikamente sind nicht geholfen.
Haben nicht geholfen.
Genau.
Er hat keinen Luftnot, kein Fieber.
Ja.
Wasser lassen und stillgang sind in Ordnung.
Er raut nicht.
Ja.
Er konsumiert geregentlich Alkohol.
Okay.
Er hat Drogenkontakt wurde verneint.
Er hat keine Allergie.
Und in der Kinderheit hat er.
Nicht Kinderheit.
Nicht Kinderheit, sondern Kindheit in der Kindheit.
Kindheit.
Ja.
In der Kindheit hat er.
Appendectomie.
Sonst keine Operation.
eine Apendectomie und eine Tonselektomie. In der Kindheit hat er nicht, er ist ja schon vergangen,
oder in der Kindheit habe er eine Apendectomie und eine Tonselektomie gehabt. Nicht hat,
sondern hatte oder habe gehabt, so wie ihr das mal sagt. Ihr sagt doch immer habe gehabt.
In der Familie, Anlamnesi findet sich Art. Hypertonie und derbites Melutus bei der Mutter,
COPD bei der Vater und Art. Hypertonie und derbites Melutus auch bei der Schwester.
Sie ist verheiratet und hat eine Tochter. Er ist verheiratet. Er war nicht im Ausland in der letzten
Zeit und ist dachdecker. Gut, okay, was noch? War das alles zum Bein? War das alles zum Bein?
Das war, fährt alles zum Bein? Also er hat Schmerzen sehr starke und ist heller und das ist gestern
aufgetreten. Sonst haben Sie nichts mehr gefragt. Haben Sie den Patienten gefragt, wann die Schmerzen
auftreten? Haben Sie den Patienten gefragt, wann die Schmerzen auftreten am Bein? Wann haben Sie das gefragt?
Er hat gestern gesagt? Nein, da habe ich verstanden. Ich habe gesagt, haben Sie ihn gefragt, wann die Schmerzen
aufgetreten sind, sondern wann die Schmerzen auftreten.
Wann die aufgetreten sind heißt, wann es angefangen hat und jetzt wann treten die Schmerzen auf heißt,
wann jetzt, wo ich das kann ausgelöst werden am Moment da, wann treten die auf. Haben Sie das
gefragt, wann die Schmerzen auftreten? Haben Sie das den Patienten gefragt? Ja, nach der Arbeit,
nach der Gartenarbeit auftreten. Nein, die Schmerzen sind nach der Gartenarbeit aufgetreten, aber wann
treten die immer auf? Okay, verstanden. Wann sind die Tränen aufgetreten, die Schmerzen oder wann
haben die angefangen? Das war nach der Gartenarbeit. Okay, haben Sie gefragt, wann die immer auftreten,
die Schmerzen? Das war ja einmalig die Gartenarbeit und jetzt danach, wann treten die immer noch auf?
Da steht es drauf Bewegung. Haben Sie das gefragt? Ja, Sie haben das doch gefragt. Sie haben doch
gefragt, wann treten die Schmerzen immer auf? Bei Bewegung oder in Ruhe haben Sie das den Patienten
gefragt? Ja, und was hat der Patient gesagt? Er sagte, beim Sitzen sind Schmerzen,
bei der Bewegung sind Schmerzen nicht immer. Genau, also die Schmerzen sind gelindert,
die Schmerzen werden im Sitzen oder in Ruhe besser und bei Bewegung nehmen Sie zu. Das heißt, wann
bei Bewegung, bei welcher Bewegung? Im Laufen. Ja, genau, sehr gut. Wenn der Patient ein paar Schritte
läuft, laufen ist nicht immer dieses Laufen. Deutschen sagen auch laufen zum Gehen. Wenn der
Patient ein paar Schritte läuft, hat der Schmerzen. Du kannst aber auch sagen geht, ist egal,
aber man sagt das so, laufen. Ja, genau. Okay, und sonst noch was gefragt auf dem Bein? Nach
Schwellung gefragt zum Beispiel? Ja, haben Sie, dann müssen Sie das jetzt auch sagen. Ja. Ich habe alles
durchsieinander geschrieben. Wenn man den klinischen Befund wieder gibt, immer den klinischen Befund.
Der klinische Befund ist, der Patient hat ein helleres Bein, er hat sehr starke Schmerzen. Wir haben
ihn gefragt auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, hat der Schmerzen bei 10 und das Bein ist kühler.
Das haben Sie auch gefragt. Das linke Bein ist kühler, es ist heller, es ist sehr schmerzhaft. Es tut
weh, wenn er ein paar Schritte läuft, es wird besser in Ruhe. Und haben Sie alles gefragt? Okay.
Sie haben das gefragt. Ich weiß ja, dass Sie das gefragt haben. Alles beim
klinischen Befund dann erzählen. Sobald man über das Bein etwas erzählt, alles erzählen über das
Bein. Dann ist es einfacher. Das andere mit dem Fieber und so, das ist nebensächlich. Erstmal nur aufs
Bein konzentrieren und das Wiedergeben, was am Bein ist. Das Bein ist nicht geschwollen,
das Bein ist kühl, das Bein ist heller, das Bein ist sehr stark schmerzhaft und das Bein tut weh,
wenn es sich bewegt. Also alles zum Bein erst mal wiedergeben. Ich weiß, dass das schwer ist,
aber dann kann man alles, was zum Bein gehört sagen und dann den Rest. Er hat auch kein Fieber,
das ist ja nebenbefundlich. Hauptbefund ist ja das Bein, das tut ja weh. Das Bein.
Okay, super. Was denken Sie denn, was das sein kann? Ja. Wofür spricht das denn? Die Symptomatik
ist ja sehr klassisch. Das ist ja eine sehr klassische Symptomatik. Was ist es denn?
Das ist PAVK. Was ist eine PAVK? Ich habe das noch nicht gelesen. Ja, wofür steht PAVK? Ja,
PAVK, Arterielle. Ja, PAVK, Arterielle. Arterielle. Verschlusskrankheit. Ja, tut ja es nicht.
PAVK, Arterielle, nicht venös, Arterielle, Verschlusskrankheit. Ja, richtig. Deswegen ist
das Bein kühl und deswegen ist das. Aber der Mann ist 44 Jahre alt. Glauben Sie, dass der Patient von
heute auf morgen eine PAVK entwickelt hat, wenn er vorher Sport gemacht hat, gelaufen hat,
nie Schmerzen hatte? Was kann es sonst noch sein außer einer PAVK? PAVK ist ja eine eigenständige
Erkrankung. Das heißt, die Gefäße, da wird irgendwie während die krankt die Gefäße. Ja,
deswegen passiert das. Das ist lokal. Was kann es noch sein, dass das Bein so kalt wird? Denken
Sie mal nach. Vielleicht tiefere Trombose? Ja, sehr gut, keine Trombose. Trombose passiert in den
Venen. Was passiert in den Arterien? Da muss etwas reinkommen. Ein Arterieller,
es muss von, wenn es von woanders her kommt, was ist das dann? Wenn das Gerinsel sich nicht
im Gefäß bildet, wie bei der PAVK, wenn die Gefäße krank sind, wenn es da nicht irgendwie
verkeigt wird, wenn das von woanders kommt, wie heißt das? Nicht Trombos, sondern
Embolli. Genau, das kann einfach irgendein Embolli sein, das ist nicht. Wir machen jetzt keine
Angiologieprüfung, aber ich will es jetzt nur sagen, das kann auch was Kardioembolisches sein.
Es kann sein, dass im Vorhof, Vorhof Lehmann sich da ein Trombos gebildet hat, es löst sich,
das geht ja nicht immer ins Gehirn, das kann ja auch runter ins Bein gehen. Ich schlage keinen Fall,
ist ja durch Vorhof Lehmann Trombos im Vorhof, es kann aber auch dahin.
Entschuldigung, das ist egal. Aber ja, PAVK war genau richtig, alles gut. Aber beim
jungen Mann ist nur eine Fangfrage, beim jungen Mann kann es auch mal was anderes sein,
weil er hat keinen Diabetes, er hat keine Arteriellehypotonien, was soll es denn sein?
Gut, sehr gut. Also das Deutsche ist gut, so darf ich jetzt mal was kritisieren bitte.
Also was machen Sie jetzt mit den Patienten erst mal? Was machen Sie jetzt mit dem
Patienten an Diagnostik? Was machen Sie? Wie gehen Sie vor? Ganz einfach, strukturiert
vorgehen, was machen Sie bei dem Patienten als erstes? Er hat solche schmerzmützliche Untersuchungen.
Ja genau, Sie haben Schmerzmützchen gegeben, das haben Sie super gemacht. Sie haben erst mal den Patienten versorgt.
Was machen Sie als nächstes?
Ich untersuche den Patienten. An am Nese haben Sie gemacht und jetzt kommt die
körperliche Untersuchung. Und was untersuchen Sie, wenn Sie den Verdacht haben,
dass es eine PAVK sein könnte? Das allererste, können Sie mit dem Finger machen?
Ja, ich muss Peripera Puls anpenden.
Sie tasten die Pulse sehr gut und die sind nicht tastbar. Okay, alles klar, sehr gut.
Und dann kann man noch, aber das macht man glaube ich nicht, aber genau, ist egal.
Was machen Sie als nächstes? Einfach, aber schnell. Was machen Sie dann noch?
Um zu gucken, ob die Besuch zu heißt?
Inspektion, wie sieht das?
Sehr gut, das haben wir schon alles gemacht, an am Nese-Körper-Indersuchung.
Jetzt haben wir mit dem Finger schon, jetzt geht es weiter. Labor, was machen
Sie denn im Labor?
Ähm, vielleicht für die Embolie kann ich Ddmer.
Ja gut, alles, Blutbild, Elektrolyte, Grimmung ist wichtig und dann auch die Ddmer würde ich mitmachen.
Ja, sehr gut, okay. Nichts Spezifisches eigentlich.
Und dann weiter, was machen Sie als nächstes? Labor und dann?
Bildgebung.
Was ist die beste Bildgebung bei PRVK? Moment, kann man das sehen.
Und Tröschen, Sonografie, Doklar, Sonografie.
Doklar, sehr gut, eine Doppler-Untersuchung, genau.
Und dann sehen Sie eine Doppler-Untersuchung und dann können Sie ja noch einen Angier machen,
wenn Sie wollen ein CT-Angier, aber in der Regel reicht der Doppler schon aus, wenn Sie das da sehen.
Und, ähm, was machen Sie, wenn Sie eben Doppler einen höhergradigen Verschluss,
denn Sie machen natürlich auch einen CT-Angier, nehmen wir mal an, ja.
Haben Sie das Angierbild und es ist verschlossen, was machen Sie dann?
Was machen Sie, wenn es verschlossen ist? Nehmen wir mal an, eine wichtige Arterie unten,
dann haben wir keine Ahnung, Arterie, TBI alles oder was weiß ich, ist verschlossen, was machen Sie dann?
Äh, weiter.
Sie sind ein kleines Haus, Sie sind ein kleines Haus.
Ich muss dieses Patienten verliehen.
Diesen Patienten, nicht dieses.
Genau, wohin?
In Brust-Chest-Center, oder ich weiß es nicht, gehört es, eine Grosse?
Nein, ich habe nicht gehört.
Nein, nicht wohin?
Äh, in eine Grosse.
Ja, in welcher Abteilung? Sie müssen telefonieren.
Es ist nachts, es ist nachts 2 Uhr.
Es muss eine Klinik aufnehmen, das heißt, Sie müssen gezielt anrufen.
Wo rufen Sie denn an?
Ähm, wie heißt das?
Ich weiß es, aber ich schüroge ihn.
Gefäßchirurgie, Gefäßchirurgie.
Gefäßchirurgie, ja.
Gefäßchirurgie, genau.
Es muss in die Gefäßchirurgie.
Sehr gut.
Und der muss schnell verlegt werden, der muss verriert werden.
So, jetzt muss ich meine Kritik loswerden.
Alles war super.
Ich habe das schon gemacht.
Deutsch war super.
Alle wirklich gut gemacht, aber zu ernst.
Ein bisschen lächeln.
Es ist schön, wenn Sie lachen.
Aber die Patienten auch, und auch beim Vorstellen des Patienten,
das ist wichtig.
Der Prüfer muss Sie mögen.
Ein bisschen lächeln.
Wirklich, ich meine es ernst.
Es ist so.
Ja, lauter reden.
Und ein bisschen lächeln.
Das war es.